all right how to read code all of these
examples will be a bit different I'm
gonna try to give you an atom example
there's been a lot of vs code there's
been a lot of pycharm my preferred
editor is atom though I believe you
could do many of these ideas any
preferred IDE developing environment in
order for me to get this kind of
interactivity an atom I've installed a
plug-in called hydrogen hydrogen is
basically a plug right into Jupiter and
it allows you to execute code line by
line why am I doing this well live
coding is a little bit crazy except this
is going to be live coding with some
training wheels
everything's been pre baked so that I'm
not going to type you can see I'm quite
tall and like I'd have to be down here
but my thesis in this whole presentation
is that reading code is a lot like
archaeology where you're not just going
to read it from top to bottom you kind
of have to like scrape and dig and
figure out what's going on inside of
these things if you don't like the
archaeology metaphor perhaps surgery
might be appropriate so again reading
code is really trying to understand what
a specific block of code is trying to do
so I'm going to take you through in
these next 30 minutes an example of
reading some code and to make it a bit
fun I thought hey what let's try to
build a rock-paper-scissors bot I had
this idea because I'm teaching a full
time data science program in Canada and
my students just really needed to be
introduced to this concept of reading
code and so I went online and tried to
find a block of code that we could
leverage and that kind of retool inspect
and see exactly what was going on I
chose rock paper scissors because humans
are terrible at generating random
numbers we think we're quite good but
we're not we have predictable patterns
I read this on reddit a couple days ago
in rock-paper-scissors you should just
always pick paper because men will
choose rock and on top of that thesis I
kind of believe that like hey maybe it's
the case that someone's gonna hit rock
rock paper or paper paper scissors
there's gonna be some type of
predictable pattern and in order to
dissect this type of pattern I thought
that I could use a Markov chain to try
and decide what's going on Markov chains
are quite complex though and so I wanted
a starting point and found one googling
so this is a wonderful article guest
posted by and Kerr and Ken who
apparently has a book I was reading
through this blog post and literally
just grabbed his code and wanted to
better understand what was going on so
all of these slides or rather they're
not slides all of these examples would
be available at this github link so if
you want to follow along please grab it
and then if you want to read the post on
which this is derived you can go to this
website but the first step in reading
any piece of code is pretty much just
copy and paste it and so that's exactly
what I've done here
here is the block of code that I lifted
and straight away it seems not too bad I
can sort of what I can sort of
understand what's going on seems to be
an initialization function a next state
method a generate state method seems to
be using numpy not quite sure what this
thing is doing just yet we'll have to
give this a better look but when we're
lifting code I like to put it into atoms
such that I can instantiate all of it
and pretty much just run and see what's
happening so provided in the article was
this transition matrix that defined
where you are and where you're gonna go
it seemed a bit clunky but I'm just
gonna try it let's see what happens
stuff this into an instance of the
Markov chain call it weather chain and
then define where the states would be it
seems like that's what the author was
doing with this block of code so I'm
just gonna run
see what the outputs might be generated
from this there seems to be an argument
in next state called current state okay
that makes sense what does the Markov
chain do it tries to grab your current
state and predict the next thing so it
seems like if I just run this method
call okay hmm it's just generating some
outputs oh you see rainy but most often
it would hit sunny because that's the
place in transition matrix so to snowy
will look like this
and then if I look through the next
method that was implemented in this
class there's generate states seems like
it might take a number we'll see what's
going on here so all I've done is I've
copy and paste of the code I've run the
pieces of code in my atom editor with
hydrogen and I haven't done anything
interesting
I understand what I need to put into it
I understand what I'm gonna get out of
it I don't really understand how it
works just yet
I see it's using a dictionary don't
really know what this piece is doing
just yet in order to better understand
and read this code properly I will drop
it into a brand new text space and I
will try to do some surgery surgery that
is gonna be as minimally invasive as
possible and so what I've come up with
is let's just grab the pieces from the
script before the transition matrix and
the states load those up and my version
of minimal invasive surgery will
actually be chop off the head so what I
recommend when you're dealing with a
class and want to better understand
what's exactly going on inside of this
thing is take all of the code and
literally just lop off the head so if
you do that I'll just comment these bits
out and I'll replace them with something
that wasn't intended for this but I'm
gonna grab mark from unit tests and
build up this self object this will
allow me to keep all
the pieces of code pretty much exactly
as it is so I'm going to lop off the
head bring in mock and self so I'm gonna
bring in this object it doesn't look
like all that much but it will allow me
to proceed with business as usual so now
I can run each of these pieces of code
and everything will actually just work
so if I go look at self now this is the
amazing part of the atom and hydrogen is
you can actually just highlight bits of
code and see exactly what's going on
inside of these things so once i've
walked off the head i have brought in
this self mark object now it's time for
me to kind of dig deeper and see what's
going on in these blocks of code that
maybe i don't fully understand just yet
this seems confusing to me okay that
seems to be like we're all have you left
things going I want to now better
inspect and move a fine-tooth comb
through all of these pieces yes so right
now we have States this is rainy sunny
and snowy this is the transition matrix
that matches up to this I want to see
exactly what each of these pieces are
doing so I'm gonna run mock building
this object I'm going to see what this
type of thing does okay actually just
looks like it's turning it into an
umpire array and making sure that it is
at least 2d cool I'll put States into
States and now I want to see what this
thing's doing so right away I'm thinking
that something doesn't sit right we're
trying to build up two different
dictionaries that seemingly I think do
the exact same thing so it looks like
one maps it to integers and the other
just Maps it back to the original States
I understand why that is maybe happening
we're gonna do things
top of a transition matrix and a matrix
can only accept integer locations so I
get that but I think I'm gonna have to
come back to these pieces they seem okay
for now the code works I have
I love code that works hope that works
this code that works but I think we can
do a better job and I'm gonna come back
to these things but this is just a big
long piece of code to effectively map it
seems the state's back to integer
placements so I'll go grab a current
state Sonny I'll stuff it back into next
state I'll run this piece and see that
oops if I actually run everything again
I perhaps did something out of order
there we are still giving me state
outputs but I think we need to now go
deeper on this object so again with atom
hydrogen reading code is pretty damn
easy I can collect and rather inspect
exactly what's going on from the inside
edge so current state we know is defined
as Sonny I can go look at this and see
okay that's Sonny well going into the
index dict this is just a dictionary I'm
gonna pass and Sonny and get back zero
okay yeah that totally makes sense we
are mapping zero to Sonny and then I
think what is happening here is this is
your transition matrix and with a little
bit of sub setting we can pass in rows
and columns this would just be the 0th
row and all the columns I would expect
this block of code to just give me the
first row back and that seems like
exactly what it's supposed to do
looking at random choice what I know
about random choice is if I just drop
this in I can give it any sort of one
two three and I believe it will just
give me one or two back
seems like this P is actually just
modifying the probabilities of the array
associated with this
things so it seems like I'm just gonna
pass in the States and it's gonna map it
to probabilities okay cool I sort of
know what's going on now I hope you can
follow as well with these pieces I'm now
gonna generate or rather see what
generates States is meant to do I'll
build this loop and now I'll try to take
apart the loop to better understand
what's going on I've already done this
but effectively a copy and paste it and
then I'm gonna grab the for I in range
number and just like let's start at one
see what that does so we're going to
build the future States objects set it
to one run our next state oh that's the
thing that we just teased apart up here
so run the next state I think we're just
stuffing that into an object called an S
pending that to the future and then
setting current state to the state that
we already built so looking into future
States now oh it's sunny actually seems
like this eye business isn't even
captured in the loop so breaking apart
actually seeing what was going on I now
notice that hey I could probably replace
that with an underscore to kind of
denote to me that like this doesn't
really matter it doesn't matter which
iteration were in the loop it just
matters that we're running a loop a
whole bunch of times to generate a bunch
of states okay so we've gone a little
bit deeper now I want to make some
changes I saw that this doesn't feel all
that right and this is probably pretty
verbose I'd like to change this to make
it more legible so that others that are
reading my code could better understand
what's going on in here so move into
adjust and while I'm making these
adjustments I was talking about
rock-paper-scissors and I'm giving you
sunny rainy and snowy well that was the
variables that the original post
described so I'm going to take sunny
rainy and snowy and in fact
I'm seeing this transition matrix now
and I don't even know how I would codify
rock-paper-scissors into this because
what I'm trying to do is build a
rock-paper-scissors bought that would
try and beat human exploiting the fact
that a human probably isn't the best at
generating random numbers so it seems
like this transition matrix is actually
doing most of the work how would I even
build that in the first place because
I'm probably gonna be getting states
that are like oh it was
rock-paper-scissors or in a string of
dates it was sunny sunny rainy rainy
snowy it's probably gonna look at this
and so my transition matrix isn't
actually all that super helpful I'm
gonna need to figure out how I can move
my states into something that looks sort
of like this and back out the decision
matrix so as we move forward let's just
go to rock-paper-scissors and replace
sunny with rock and snowy with paper and
scissors with rainy so I'll do that here
I'll build up the states and effectively
when I reach this point in trying to
trying to read this code I went to
Google and googled how to build a
transition matrix found this post you
can go look at it but in the interest of
time I'm just gonna drop it in copy and
paste it and just run it because that
was the first recommendation so the code
that I grabbed from Stack Overflow to
build up one of these transition
matrices looks like this
so immediately not really sure what's
going on but I'll execute the code and
try to get to know put so seems like the
last bit is stored in probs
we'll see what probs does and that looks
sort of like a matrix except it's been
normalized across the entire thing so
that's not precisely what I want but it
gets me pretty close so I'm gonna
backtrack a little bit and try and see
what was going on in this whole winds
window function business so with window
it grabbed
and it tried to get me closer to prob so
I'll execute this block of code and oh
no it's a generator so I'll explode it
with a list and maybe just inspect the
first five pieces and it's trying to
match up okay what was going on here
rock rock paper rock scissors oh I see
what it's doing it's building rock to
rock rock to paper just chaining the
last piece in the next piece well hmm
this seems like a big old function to
just put the place where you're at to
the next place when I was reading this a
light sort of went off and I imagined
that hey I could just take these two
lists stagger one of them and then zip
them up this is just like a vanilla
python function that comes batteries
included so if I staggered this list
zipped it up and then peeked inside with
list I'd be able to replicate everything
that this function did appear so by
running the code but getting to the
output something went off and me knowing
that I could just reach for zip and just
replace all of that nonsense with code
that looks like this so we're still not
there we need to get two probabilities
trying to take States we're trying to
move into a transition matrix such so we
can build our Markov chain
so taking one step forward we will I
think go into counts and see what this
was doing so counts it looks like it was
just going from one state to the other
and counting them up well I know there's
another Python tool for that and
collections called
counter and so what I can do is take our
zipped-up stagger States force it into a
list put into a new object and run
counter on top of that but running
counter I think we get roc-roc five rock
paper to pretty much the same output
okay now with these pieces it looks like
this is just a a dictionary and with
tuples as the hashes and values as the
counts maybe I can take this and run
items on top of it
unpack this thing and have X Y count be
captured in each of these places and
I'll just stuff it into a panda's data
frame that will have those locations and
these counts so I've taken someone
else's code from Stack Overflow read
through it executed the code see what
was going on and now I'm almost there
it's still not perfect but the original
code wasn't perfect either so with this
I'm going to not adjust but refactor my
code and go over here so running from
the top again we'll bring in rock paper
scissors and actually before we get to
the transition matrix creation thing I
think we need to solve this problem
because I wasn't thrilled with it when
we started we've got these two different
things that are doing the exact same
thing well not exact same thing but the
reverse of each other I don't want them
to have like separate nests I want it to
be all packaged together I want to be
able to run it and I want to be able to
keep things clean well as a data
scientists I know in my toolbox that I
have something called label encoder that
is imported from scikit-learn
pre-processing label encoder is this
overpowered tool I think that allows you
to take hey our states that we had our
rock paper and scissors we can fit
States into this label encoder and
actually run something called fit
transform that will take all of these
states and transform them into integers
everything I think needs to be an
integer because we're doing index
location in a matrix and we can't just
plop rock-paper-scissors in there
so with this chain and with label
encoder I believe now I can run a method
called inverse transform this will take
the generated chain
and nap things back this seems to be
exactly what this block of code was
trying to do and just peeking out what
was going on in this thing it seems like
I was mapping rock to zero and zero to
rock
well what label encoder does is exactly
that and there's a built-in inverse
transform method so I'll take this chain
that's been transformed I'll do the same
bits that we did in the last script so
the staggered chain that was zipped
together
I'll run counter on top of it and then
I'll describe and try to build out the
matrix to pre-populate it so to do this
I'll find out how many unique states
there possibly are it should just be
three and I'll quickly build out a
matrix with a list comprehension to do
that for me okay so this would be zero
zero zero one zero two
I can now unpack this whole counter
object and then fill it in with some
vanilla Python so this is now my matrix
I think we've got enough code going on
at this point to wrap it up so we will
put it into a function called change a
matrix this is the exact code above and
run this on top of our chain so here now
is the matrix but we need to normalize
it such that I can pass it into the
transition matrix choosing function it
needs to be a probability that will sum
to one so is this normal
no it's not yet but my normalize
function can be pretty damn easy it's
just taking the sum of the entire row
and it's dividing it by whatever the row
and column index is by the entire row so
when I run this here's just a couple
examples treat this as a row these would
be summed up swarm as with this because
it's a matrix I need to apply this
function on top of everything and so
I'll just iterate through every single
row for row and matrix do the
normalizing process append and bring it
so now I can take the entire matrix and
stuff it into a transition matrix that
looks alright so now we've gone from a
process of chained together States and I
have pretty much what I need to generate
the Markov chain so now I'm just gonna
run it and take the function and just
rebuild it with my pieces before we had
this whole big block using the index
dict
but instead I'm going to use my whole
label encoder transform inverse
transform business so I can peek inside
and see these would be the classes
here's the transition matrix let's run
it eh seems like it works so now that I
have most of the pieces ready to go I'm
gonna package it up this seems like
something that would be useful to other
people so this is the code that I'd come
up with it's not all that different safe
for this piece here as I was building
this presentation was like Oh like I've
kind of gotten rid of numpy I've gotten
rid of pandas be cool if I just could
build this all in pure Python and so I
spent some time building out a label
encoder for myself it's not all that
difficult maybe you can take this
presentation the ideas that I've shown
you and kind of peel apart this for
yourself I knew I wouldn't have time to
fully explain it but the rest of the
functions convenience functions to
change matrix the normalized the
normalized matrix they've all been
presented you've all seen them and now
I've just taken the Markov chain that
was given on the blog post and rewritten
some of these methods to do exactly that
so now it's time to play with this thing
I've actually packaged it up for you
it's available on my github or pi PI as
Mark so you can pip install it and what
this will allow me to do is bring in a
Markov chain from Mark take the chain
that we've been playing with rock rock
paper rock scissors build up that chain
and now predict
next states generate a whole bunch of
next states or just use something
different if you read the synopsis of
this presentation I made reference to
Shakespeare's like Oh actually be kind
of cool if I went to Gutenberg and
grabbed a text of Shakespeare and see
how well my Markov chain could do on top
of this
who needs GPT too so we'll build two
functions to quickly go through this
take the entire text of maybe something
like a fellow and generate some
sentences using our pure Python Markov
chain builder and so I've been running a
couple of these they seem like they look
like they could be Shakespeare there's a
bunch of just nonsense I'll let you
through read through a couple and see if
they pass the sniff test most don't I
wanted to take something like oz so The
Wizard of Oz see if I could do the exact
same thing runs pretty quick this is
actually running through the entire book
did it in like 20 seconds sorry 20
milliseconds with pure Python here's
some Allyson or sorry some Wizard of Oz
Markov chain generated sentences and
they're not perfect but they do alright
so in summary what should you take from
us reading code is a lot like
archaeology it's a lot like surgery and
if you're gonna perform surgery needs a
tool my preferred tool is atom in
hydrogen and I'd like you to not be
scared of copying pasting code make sure
that you are given credit where credit
is due and making changes that are
appropriate but when you're copying
pasting code in order to read it get to
an output as quick as possible see what
the inputs are see what the outputs are
that gives you a better sense for what
was going on if your code is
encapsulated in some type of class these
things are hard to get into except if
you just lop off the head and use my
little self mock object instead once
you've done that rerun all the
attributes and the methods to make sure
that you didn't break anything and then
start inspecting though
blocks of code with a fine-tooth comb
that you are sure they're doing the
heavy lifting if something is especially
complex you should probably take it do
some inlining see what each step is
trying to do and then peek inside of
those things that are iterators by
exploding it with some type of list
loops can often be difficult to parse
and see what's going on and so d looping
the loops by just extracting the code
seems to work
you should try and slim down and
replicate your outputs from those
borrowed bits of code and anytime you're
working with a matrix you should
probably use label Ben Reiser label and
coder these things are just overpowered
they're really great and then this
should be obvious but maybe it's not
often make sure after you've made all
these changes that things still work
before you try to encapsulate and then
in a class but that is my presentation
here is the tool that you can use to
play with it all of the code is
available at this repository I think I
have two minutes
and so I'll toss it over for some
questions thanks for attention
[Applause]